hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we are going to watch
Game of Thrones cast react to season 8
script finale I'm assuming this is taken
from footage from a documentary that a
few people have asked us to check out I
haven't seen it yet I'd rather watch
this compilation instead before we get
into this I would like to say thank you
to everyone and helped us have a
successful month over at our patreon for
the month of May if you haven't joined
our patreon page yet what are you doing
we do weekly Q&A is over there as well
as TV show reaction stream along for
many shows that includes my hero
academia attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and one punch man
as well as Gotham Jon did all of Hana me
Hillhouse he's covering Cobra Kai season
two right now and supernatural and of
course the stream along for all a Game
of Thrones Season eight or over there as
well he also does music video coverage
so hop on over to our patreon page if
you're interested let's check this out
we don't wear headphones
that's adorable I wanna bite king cake
[Music]
yeah not okay
[Music]
Wow Wow the Nicki turns and sees John
coming for him is this going to be an
epic fight no the night King raises his
arm slowly John knows what that means
the Dead begin to rise
Jorah the end all battles are very much
pummeled and pierced but somehow he was
fighting White's plunge their knives
into him he takes more punishment than
the great Paul and still somehow Doris
stands a defensive screen Dany tries to
rouse Dora but he is gone oh dear God's
Word the 19 walks with methodical
terrifying calm he stops before bran and
raises his sword to strike but something
is hurtling toward him out of the
darkness
[Applause]
[Music]
Harrington didn't read the description
for Dragonstone beach night gray road
leads fairest hands bound down the beach
I saw the gif of him drogon spews fire
on him but we don't watch our old friend
burn instead we see the reactions of
those who knew them lorry execute
another trader nature's standing before
the iron from Danny steps forward and
kisses the man she loves the perfect
their eyes closed his hand behind her
head Danny's eyes suddenly as she
fainted John's eyes open as well already
filling with tears for a moment neither
moves is it moving will make this real
we see John with his hands still on the
hilt of the dagger he just lost the
Danny's heart
her strength leaves her and she
collapses to the marble he keeps her in
his arms and she falls down I didn't
notice that the first time oh damn I
didn't realize how motorist I got it
watching on Instagram thing Wow winter
is going in the trash
wow wow I saw they like a gift very Zach
yeah yeah you look really pissed
he's been vocal too about you know not
liking the last couple seasons so much
and he like his character was
underserved and yeah yeah yeah the man
does that seem quite a pair of their
bubble there of like [ __ ] this right
here in the thumb bubble you can see
that you know yeah he's he's by far the
most stoic of all the but like
pronouncedly stoic of all the reactions
even the people who aren't really
responding much just look like they're
reading but there's a lot in his face
yeah and that was cool to see how
enthusiastic the whole cast was about
arya killing the night king yeah cuz i
had heard from emilia clarke saying that
she had read the script before doing the
table read but kid harrington said that
he didn't want to read it until they got
to the table read he wanted to
experience it I feel like that's what I
wanted and that makes sense why his
reaction was was to that degree so
emotional yeah yeah I saw that like a
little Instagram video of it but I
didn't realize he was being choked up
about it that didn't register to me when
I've watched the video
looking very emotional I hope he's okay
man he does not seem to be taking the
end of the show terrific well he
apparently he's been out I read a little
bit about it apparently the show itself
has had taken a toll on him since he was
resurrected back because he became like
the main focus of the show yeah like
you're the star now of this show the
pressure and the weight of it and you
know it was 20 years when all that I
can't imagine what the pressures I've
heard a lot of people have come to his
support like via social media which of
course that's usually led to people will
often criticize make jokes like Oh
season 8 finale must have really been
that bad or people judging of come on
man you're you guys you're Jon Snow you
got the biggest show in the world it's a
lot easier to say that than it is when
you're in the bubble it's a lot harder
to just have nothing but full blown
appreciation it's hard to do that when
you're the focal point of the pressure
rather than having to carry so much and
then there has been so much criticism
towards almost everyone involved with
the show cast and crew for this final
season and I've been public about it
when we do the reactions and reviews
I've stated how I felt about this show
but I don't go out of my way to attack
this show on social media like I don't
agree that it's a lazy show I don't
agree with the way it was written I
don't agree with a lot of the choices
however I still think it's one of the
best shows of all time despite its last
season I still think it's one of the
best and it is sad like these people
work their asses look at the amount of
secrecy they've had if Benioff and Weiss
really didn't give two shits about this
show do you think they would have wanted
this level of protection on their on
their final season to be like put them
all out so we could all reason we gonna
[ __ ] shred them right away you know
yeah yeah and I mean it is kind of
fascinating with all the bitching
there's been and with all the
speculation there has been I mean I've
been wondering about their relationship
to everybody because they steer the ship
and by all accounts at least the length
the duration of the show is their
decision yeah so especially knowing that
this has taken a toll on not only the
fan base but the cast and everything I
just wonder what that they made that
crack about like them it's like a big
family except we don't all hate each
other and I'm like I wonder out what the
internal vibes are like because like I
sympathize for Kit Harington a lot
because you are a part of this family
that's been so much of your life and for
him and
it blew my mind when they showed the
footage of the first season table yeah
how young everybody is how different the
cast has no idea their life was gonna
probably change this much yeah an idea
for somebody like him you know like you
you grow up a lot of your formative
years being a giant cog in this
juggernaut machine and then when that
thing ends yeah I got imagine the
handling of the season the details of
the plot aside like a whole foundational
aspect of their life has now changed
I mean people some people can get to get
really hard when they graduate high
school graduate colleges or even years I
mean like we you and I went to school
from first to eighth grade together and
I remember that with it when 8th grader
was done all going our separate ways
like crowds younger for me that was a
devastating time life's different yeah
and when you commit 10 like this is
whatever amount of hours of television
we've watched I don't know what number
you multiply that by because it's at
least like a year per season and then
promoting and then bonding and then
prepping it like there's it's all that's
Pro 10 years they had they have all been
in this circle and not just the cast a
lot of the crew the producers as well
like that one producer they were showing
at the end she looked very like torn up
but I can imagine this was a very sad
experience that's why I'd steer clear
from like attacking the filmmakers and
the cast involved like trying to put out
tweets and stuff like if we're doing a
review of it I will be blunt honest
about how I feel about it but I'm not
gonna be like sign a petition for the
end of the day I mean everybody's people
and it's all just a collaborative effort
to make something cool and and I mean
for as much crap as Benioff and Weiss
get I understand at least the conundrum
of like yeah this has been like a decade
of are let's like the one story we've
gotten to tell but this was really cool
just to see everybody take it in it
extends that reach of community because
to being such an ensemble cast that we
have all kind of grown with over the
years it just brings you that much
further it's like when we all saw the
night King moment and freaked out it was
cool to kind of feel like you're almost
sharing that reaction with them yeah
just so far removed and
that's beautiful there's some beautiful
stuff well guys what do you think about
this compilation who had the reaction
that you treasure the most send positive
vibes to Kit Harington in the universe
while you're at it before I wrap this up
I like to get a patron the day shots a
man named Niraj Krishnan Niraj I know
your overall pretty satisfied with this
game with Thrones finale I'm happy for
you dude
I know it's like pretty 50/50 here I
hope you stay on the positive spectrum
of things even though I'm not really on
the positive side of the way the season
ended I'm glad you are if anyone is
watching this is on the positive side
stay that way
defend what you love at all costs Niraj
if someone tries to convince you
otherwise strike them down right in
front of you just murder them instantly
drew chorus defeat negativity by killing
it with a positive attitude break that
wheel with another wheel subscribe to
the reel rejects click that notification
bell if you liked this video hit the
like button checks on patreon